Donavan what do you do on a day off
today what should you have a favorite
office episode I would say probably you
know when the white tries to start the
fire training that's pretty funny to me
just just the whole goal all the antics
today was well he actually starts a fire
too which is the the great part of that
- yes
did you ever see that funny character
did you see the basketball one in the
warehouse when Kevin's just like
everybody up I
that was this no one would think Kevin
would be the guy who's going to go off
right and what else do you binge watch
shows about four or five times -
entirely wait Burn Notice yes sir really
that sound like USA Network in it well
it was but it's all word now and I had
to the DVD first no no no watching on my
xbox and whatnot are you a street famous
like if you're walking around Houston
can you walk around and get noticed no
actually I can't walk around anymore
it's kind of weird to me now I can't
just go anywhere I think this all
happened in the matter of two months
since the dunk contest it really changed
a lot of there's a lot of stuff for me
give me the city where you you can't
walk out like that soon as you walk out
in car okay aside from the Utah I'm
talking about a road down here
[Laughter]
now that would be bad if you nobody knew
you and Utah cities there's too much
there's also breaks it's like I'm others
I can't finish it
yeah back home yet to New York in
Connecticut but um
la la the big one has pretty much state
LA they look for celebrities and
athletes like people look around for him
so I would say la probably a big one who
is the most famous person you've met
this rookie season Eddie Murphy Latifah
that's what really okay I was really
like a kid in a kid in the candy shop
when I met all these all these
celebrities and they know and what not
and then gonna dunk contests allowed me
people realize who I was and then it was
kind of like that's pretty cool too even
though my name let alone know that I
exist but um yeah those are the huge
chance to rap as well what was your
welcome to the NBA moment I think when
Russ Russ in the breast Paul George
Carmelo ended up having a conversation
with me after the game like they did you
know I knew Paul George and Carmelo from
playing with them this past summer and
worked out the one not but when once can
you talk to me it was really like kind
of crazy cousin talk to anybody at all
got wondering the game and what that
after so for that to happen was pretty
pretty exciting for me what's it like to
guard James Harden it's tough you know
he is tough to guard oh he's so
unpredictable but you know eventually I
get back to the step next week
you just don't know when it's gonna
happen and you know yeah so much as
losing his repertoire that uh it makes
it impossible you know
hasn't any walk didn't we've studied it
and we have her way of guarding it now
after game work but it's confident he
takes a lot of job was a funny thing the
guy who ditched a collage it was like
that yeah only one spot but you know we
have guys who are locked it and right as
you decided we watch the filming think
that likely dr. Goodall he's a hell of a
player so you guys are gonna shut him
down I think what Donovan is saying this
the Utah Jazz are going to can we get
breaking news here the sounder there
yeah breaking news on the Dan Patrick
show Donovan Mitchell says they will
shut down James Harden game - did I miss
quote you on that diamond oh I did just
as hard and talked anything to you does
he say anything and does it in silence
which is which I respect
does anybody talk to you I mean you're a
rookie so they have to talk to you might
give you a little grief Katie let me
hear it a little bit for you my shot was
made you know game day know what you let
you know if the South goes down
Devin Booker he had a Donovan Mitchell
Utah Jazz guard going to shut down James
Harden in Game two
that'll be tomorrow night and he joins
us now is there still hope that you win
Rookie of the Year do you care and
people seem to disagree that untested no
one expected us to make the playoffs as
a whole still you know like this a big
accomplishment itself and we're not just
want to go but um you know like I said
that award is one morning I'm a team
player you know I'm seeing first that's
my model over here and you know I yeah
so I'm not too worried of the word but
it definitely caused that to have fun
with the antics I like it I like it did
you play any other sports growing up I
did I grew up playing baseball I was
pretty heavy on baseball my dad was a
mess I was able to be exposed to the
Major League Baseball's and all those
guys at a young age I really thought I
was gonna be me - hopefully okay
I broke my wrist off my year and I ended
up mmm stick doing basketball which I
don't think was a bad - it best
who's your baseball player your idol
growing up Mike Piazza was was one of my
favorites just I don't know he just had
a way about him I just I just lost you
know now I hated being a catcher I
couldn't eyes blink that's a bad trade
as a catcher Donovan I'm trying to
embrace the new uniforms here what do
you think of the new uniforms with the
jab yeah whatever color they are what do
you think I love I love the different
you know and they have a deeper meaning
to it which I love as well I didn't know
into about the second time we warm and I
started understanding at seven years oh
you look so cute oh it looks almost
identical from our uniforms so but I
love it already
it's my favorite color so I'm a bit of a
[ __ ] the teleplay when it comes to my
shoes as well have you gone through
those national parks have you gone to
Zion in any of those places
and yeah oh my godness done when you got
it okay you're gonna do that some of you
know how far the driver was at first
have somebody Drive you have Rubio Drive
you a little
just a little okay I I gave him a hard -
I didn't mean to give him a hard time
when I can shoot better than a pro then
I'm gonna give him a little bit of a
hard time and I can shoot better than
Rubio can Donnelly I mean it's been I've
been waiting eight years for him to you
know make a couple of jumpers in a row
and you know I like that he's playing
well for you guys I'm not big on the man
bun and I don't think you are either
right he looks like Jesus hey when he
shoots like Jesus let me know no who's
third year in the league
he only had 13 threes made in and he was
part of the finals you know you know I
know but I'm just saying I have a better
jumper than Ricky Rubio and look you
should you should back your guy if you
were done okay I love your game you
should be Rookie of the Year but you
gotta be you have to know when maybe not
to back your guy and just say you know
what your jumper is wet and I get that
and you have a better jumper that Ricky
Rubio does Rubio looks better and it's a
better passer but do you doesn't have a
better jumper just sand on okay we're
gonna agree to disagree but uh hey have
fun and I'm looking for Harden to barely
get 20 points in Game two you got him on
lockdown right Congrats Congrats on the
season go back to watching the office
and thanks for joining us that's Donovan
Mitchell
ah I gotta teach these young kids man
four more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]